formé de gens merveilleux et de jean
ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
n'oubliez pas de réagir sur notre compte
et des grammaires t france vous pouvez
prendre part au débat interpeller nos
invités au sommaire de ce mardi 2
novembre
la folie mercredi 3 novembre la
politique polémique autour du retour
clandestin de sophie petrona au mali
paris déplore l' irresponsabilité de
l'ex-otage a septuagénaire converties à
l'islam elle se dit chez elle au mali où
elle a adopté une fille et réfute avoir
agi de manière irresponsable
elle serait retournée à bamako en plein
en pleine pandémie au mois de mars au
nez et à la barbe des autorités suisses
alors comment at-elle réussi à mener son
périple en toute discrétion pourquoi
cette présence maintenue secrète est
enfin rendue publique maintenant
décryptage dans quelques instants
et on se rendra ensuite aux états unis
où la vaccination anti qu'ovide et
élargi aux
526 millions d'enfants sont concernés le
vexin toujours administré en deux fois
trois semaines d'intervalle mais avec un
dosage adapté joe biden salué un
tournant dans la bataille entre le co
vie 19 une nouvelle étape qui était
certes attendue par de nombreux parents
mais qui aussi critiqué par certains
élus dont lé gouverneur de floride et du
texas
nucléaire stop ou encore le débat est
encore une fois ouvert ce soir à
l'occasion des coques 26 il est encore
temps de réagir sur notre compte
télégramme daté français dans notre
rubrique en pensent les français on ira
justement à la rencontre du maire de
fessenheim un an après la fermeture de
sa centrale nucléaire l'élu dit avoir
été privé d'un véritable poumon
économique
témoignages à suivre à 21h
[Musique]
le retour de sophie petrona au mali
irrite c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
le gouvernement français l'ancienne
otage franco suisse a regagné à le pays
il ya sept mois de manière irrégulière
la france par la voix de gabriel attal
dénonce une forme d'irresponsabilité on
en parle avec david kelly va bonsoir
évident comment sophie petro n'a réussi
à faire son voyage de la suisse au mali
en toute discrétion
et bien stéphanie n'ayons pas peur des
mots c'est un parcours pour le moins
ubuesque un peu après sa libération en
octobre 2020 elle s'installe avec son
fils en suisse dans la petite ville de
porrentruy avec le doux rêve de
retourner au mali sophie petrona lance
alors les démarches pour obtenir un visa
mais les autorités maliennes refuse et
le quai d'orsay fait blocage attristé
est la travailleuse humanitaire elle
convainc son fils afin de l'aider à
traverser cette frontière illégalement
alors nous sommes en mars 2021 et c'est
là qu'il décide de prendre un vol de
genève jusqu'à dakar au sénégal la
septuagénaire fait passer le voyage pour
des vacances l'objectif est clair
rejoindre gao sa ville de coeur où elle
elle a créé son association qui vient en
aide aux enfants souffrant de
malnutrition tout juste arrivé à dakar
elle réussit alors à prendre à des
transports locaux comme des motos taxis
ou des bus pour franchira la frontière
et rejoindre enfin bamako ce qui fait au
total quand même 1300 km en trois jours
et à 76 ans et en toute illégalité
évidemment ce qui montre toute sa
détermination elle s'installe à bamako
on retrouve sa fille adoptive et
vendredi est dernier seulement un avis
de recherche est diffusé le document
affirme qu'elle aurait été vu vers
sikasso une ville en zone rouge donc
formellement déconseillée par l'état
français alors tout ce parcours est à
prendre évidemment au conditionnel et
avec des pincettes et david ce retour au
mali de façon clandestine suscite
l'indignation
effectivement elle porte parole du
gouvernement gabonais la taille s'est
montré ferme sur le sujet le
gouvernement déplore ce retour au mali
pour des raisons d'insécurité
principalement écoutez
nous déplorons le retour de sophie
petrona au mali
une forme d'irresponsabilité vis-à-vis
de cette sécurité à elle mais aussi
vis-à-vis de vue la sécurité de nos
militaires je rappelle que lorsque nous
avons des ressortissants qui sont prises
en otages à l'étranger ce sont nos
militaires qui vont les secourir au
péril de leur vie une certaine forme
d'irresponsabilité un terme qui ne plaît
pas à la principale intéressée parce que
oui personne ne sait où elle s sauf life
paix qu'il a eue au téléphone selon l'
agence de presse elle vivrait
actuellement dans les faubourgs de
bamako c'est pour le moins étonnant
sophie petronas élite elle choquée du
bruit causé par son retour je cite
pourquoi irresponsable je suis chez moi
ici oui je suis au mali depuis un moment
mais je ne suis pas inquiète
et je ne suis pas l inquiéter alors le
quai d'orsay et suit de près cette
affaire sans donner pour autant plus de
précisions sur la situation de sophie
petrona les autorités maliennes de leur
côté souhaitent également l appréhender
et c'est là tout le paradoxe tout le
monde tu la fermes et personne ne prend
de décision concrète reste à savoir dans
quel objectif
m merci david khalifa pour ses
explications et en échangeant de la
libération de sophie petrona et trois
autres otages deux sentiers à 17 ans
prisonnier au mali avait donc été
relâché par le pouvoir de bamako selon
la ministre des armées et florence parly
la france n'a jamais été impliqué dans
les négociations pour les libérer des
otages français dont la stratégie
libération est gardée secrète comme il
est de tradition par le gouvernement les
explications en images
[Musique]
la france ne paye pas mais la france
essaye à chaque fois de sauver ces
otages
[Musique]
m
sophie petrona qui décide donc de tout
faire pour repartir dans son pays de
coeur mettant la france dans l'embarras
comment ce retour a donc pu être
possible sans visa en pleine pandémie de
surcroît pourquoi la prends ton
seulement maintenant beaucoup de zones
d'ombré qu'on va tenter d'analyser c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
pour en parler sur ce plateau régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france bonsoir
régis à vos côtés un petit peu plus loin
on duplex jean paul garraud député
européen rassemblement national bonsoir
monsieur garraud edrisi canon mbaye
président du collectif malien de
belgique bonsoir monsieur kalambayi
merci d'être avec nous donc sept mois
déjà quand même que sophie petrona on le
rappelle son âge 75 ans est de retour on
m'indique clandestinement réussir à
faire ce périple que nous a décrit david
kelly fin alors que les demandes de
visas en précises ont été refusées deux
fois par le mali en pleine pandémie on
se souvient qu on était tous plus ou
moins assigné à résidence impossible de
voyager ça paraît complètement fou et
j'ai dit ça paraît complètement fou puis
surtout ce temps les sept mois que vous
indiquez que dans lesquelles elle aurait
été présente romani cc c'est absolument
incroyable
d'autant qu' on peut imaginer vu ses
déclarations quand elle avait été
libérée la première fois quand on est
revenu en europe elle avait signalé déjà
qu'elle souhaitait retourner vivre au
mali ce fip et ronan c'est quelqu'un qui
fait partie
du sérail locale qui est qui et une
africaine de coeur et qui a là bas donc
une fille adoptive qui a d'abord eu un
orphelinat puis donc elle a fait
beaucoup de choses et l'afrique pour
elle c'est son pays donc elle s'est dit
elle a dit qu'elle ne se plaisait pas en
suisse là on l'avait mise en résidence
et il ya cette incroyable perrig en
effet dans lequel on peut se dire mais
comment est-ce que quelqu'un qui a été
otage justement peut arriver à nouveau à
traverser les frontières
retournez dans le son pays de détention
puisque visiblement apparemment elle ne
serait pas sissoko mai à bamako
avec l'intention de revenir vivre là où
elle était quasiment jean paul garraud
on va après voilà lé plus loin dans dans
ses conséquences mais enfin sur ce
diagnostic partir comme ça sans visa
sans rien en pleine pandémie est ce que
selon vous il ya une faille tout
simplement
dans les frontières ou ton bonne lors on
ne peut pas empêcher un citoyen avec un
passeport de d'aller où il veut
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait
malheureusement que les frontières il y
en a plus et que tout ceci ressemble à
une sorte de comédie qui aurait pu être
dramatique d'ailleurs moi je j'ai de
nombreuses réactions par rapport à cela
comme de très nombreux français je peux
dire que je suis assez ou très si ce
n'est scandalisé par ce qui vient de se
passer déjà je l'avais été au moment de
la libération de sept personnes qui
avaient eu un comportement très
particulier lorsqu'elle était arrivé au
mois d'octobre 2001 sa tenue déjà le
voile islamique et enfin ces
déclarations qui étaient à la limite du
remerciement enfin c'était très très
très particulier et puis tout ce qui a
entouré cette libération dont on ne sait
d'ailleurs pas trop ce qui s'est passé
on parle effectivement déjà de 200
djihadistes qui avaient été libérés et
lâcher quand même une pause c'est direct
pour tous nos militaires et en
particulier pour les 57 militaires
français qui sont morts dont cumali en
opération en cinquante six hommes et une
femme parce que j'y cours des risques
terribles et puis donc tout ceci si vous
voulez la connotation qui ne rend son
qui auraient été versés on ne sait pas
trop alors quand j'entends
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement français
indique qu'il n'a pas pris part à tout
cela mais alors que faisait le président
de la république le ministre des
affaires étrangères le chef d'état major
des armées et d'autres ministres lorsque
effectivement l'avion transportant sept
personnes est arrivée en france non il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont bien sûr la france a participé à
cette libération est ce que c'était
vraiment une libération puisque cette
personne manifestement était-elle
vraiment otages jusqu au bout de quatre
ans soit dix ans de captivité la
première des choses qu'elle fait ou ce
qu'elle tente de faire et elle a réussi
là récemment c'est revenir effectivement
dans le pays dans lequel elle a été
enlevée en rien au comportement pour
quelqu'un qui a été en captivité mais
j'ai d'autres d'autres évidemment
réaction par rapport
on va bien évidemment sur les conditions
de cette libération des cinq and day
vous avez pouvoir peut-être nous
éclairer parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de zones d'ombré on sait
effectivement s'en est pas cachée sophie
petrona au lieu de considérer ses
ravisseurs comme des terroristes elle
les a qualifiés de groupe d'opposition
armée au régime clairement elle avait
entre guillemets sympathisé avec eux
elle s'est convertie d'ailleurs à
l'islam et on sait aussi que la
libération c'est 200 islamistes ma foi a
constitué à l'époque un vrai succès pour
pour les djihadistes il faut le rappeler
ben tout à fait en tête pour la
situation est générale et ressemble un
peu à une
tragi-comédie bien organisée mais moi
honnêtement
c'est dommage que de diane east qui ont
commis des crimes et a été libéré
contre sa libération et aussi d'autres
d'autres prisonniers etc mais
c'était un homme politique à l'époque
était qu'on voulait libérer mon premier
pas nécessairement sophie petronas il
faut le rappeler
oui mais bon ça c'est qu'on le dit mais
c'est pas les regrettés soumaila cissé
n'était pas je pense que s'ils étaient
seuls
l'implication de tous ses états elle
n'aurait pas été
comme ça c'était passé donc où il faut
pas quand même ignorer qui c'était une
française étaient les autorités
françaises en effectivement été impliqué
quand même dans la libération de ces
otages là donc ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne peut pas même si officiellement
on a tendance à démentir mais en réalité
ils ont quand même bien participé à la
libération
de sous mais là avec soshy petro
peut-être mais régis le sommier oui
est-ce que ce qu'on a ce qu'il faut
rajouter d'abord c'est que on se
souvient quand même que c'est le fils
même de sophie petrova qui avait à
l'époque attirer l'attention sur l'état
de santé de sa mère savait était son
combat jusqu'à sa libération
là visiblement
on apprend qu'il a été aussi qu'il était
au courant voire qu'ils auraient été
commandés
retour donc on peut se demander vraiment
pourquoi avoir demandé cette libération
si cette femme finalement était à l'aise
et vivait au milieu de ces groupes ça
c'est le premier point qui est obscur et
qu'il faudra éclaircir l'autre aspect
c'est que dans ces négociations là et
aujourd'hui à d'autres niveaux parce que
là il s'agissait de groupe qui détenait
donc soul amy a saoulé soumaila cissé et
ce fip et romain ces deux personnes à
l'époque donc il y avait une négociation
qui était en cours aujourd'hui une
négociation que les maliens ne naît
aujourd'hui les maliens sont passés un
autre niveau d'hier il négocie
directement avec ryad al ghali qui est
donc le leu leu comment l'un des chefs
djihadistes et et amadou pouffa qui est
donc le chef de la katiba macina donc
ils ont entrepris des négociations
directes avec des personnes que les
troupes françaises sur place ont dans le
viseur et cherche à éliminer donc on est
dans un dans une partie il ya évidemment
dans la perle dans la non cela par des
maliens de la présence de sophie pétrole
1 une manière encore une fois
d'embarrasser les français on est dans
une situation où la france les relations
entre la france et le mali sont
extrêmement tendues mais les maliens
aujourd'hui son talent 7e qui qu'il mène
ces négociations et et dans ce cadre là
bon pourquoi avoir attendu sept mois
peut-être que il y avait aussi des
menaces que est également que que se fit
pétrin redevienne aux tâches c'était une
possibilité mais en tout cas on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que la france est
et quand même même si elle participe de
2,2 de certaines négociations
elle est quand même tenu à l'écart de
beaucoup de choses et qu'aujourd'hui
on négocie au maître directement avec
des gens que nos soldats sont censés tu
es donc il ya un interrogations
légitimes je pense aujourd'hui sur le
sens de la mission de la france la
mission barkan emmanuel macron à tignes
est à signaler la fin de cette opération
ça fait huit ans que la france est
présente au mali aujourd'hui il faut
quand même revoir les choses de fond
parce que le mali que le main event
intégrer des groupes comme les minimes
ou avoir des dialogues avec eux ou en
tout cas tenter de les faire revenir
dans l'échiquier national c'est une
possibilité peut-être que ça se fera
contre le vivier est ce qui est des
choses qui est donc l'émanation des
chais qui se trouve plus au sud avec
lequel il ya peu de négociation possible
mais en tout cas ce que le gouvernement
malien tente de faire notamment via
l'imam dicko qui est toujours un petit
peu à la manoeuvre dans ses dents dans
ce type de négociation bien on remarque
que on est au plus haut niveau
aujourd'hui en discussion le
gouvernement malien avec des chefs de
groupes terroristes 'sur une possible
réponse dans cette france à lesquin on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas continuer
avec une opération markalou même des
opérations de forces spéciales qui
disait à éliminer les chefs djihadistes
quand le gouvernement malien lui même
négocié avec eux jean paul garraud dans
le prolongement de ce que vient de dire
régis le sommier c'est vrai que un
journaliste proche de sophie près trône
à anthony aux faucheurs qui s'est un peu
exprimée dans tous les médias
aujourd'hui affirme en tout cas que la
suisse savait qu'elle repartirait
d'ailleurs l'avait dit dès le début la
france savait manifestement qu'elle
était revenue à bamako d'ailleurs elle
ne se cachait pas dans les rues de la
ville l'information a commencé à
circuler il ya quatre jours après la
publication sur les réseaux sociaux par
justement la gendarmerie malienne ça
veut dire quoi vous êtes d'accord avec
ce diagnostic de registre sommier la
france est manifestement un petit peu
tenu à l'écart des choses
écoutez moi je suis là aussi effaré de
voir la situation de la france parce que
derrière le cap et ronin c'est en fait
la france elle même est complètement
discrédité et qui a nouvelle fois une
nouvelle fois est tenue pour en quelque
sorte la risée du monde comment peut-on
imaginer une situation comme celle là
une situation où la france est tenue à
l'écart
de ce qui se passe actuellement c'est à
dire de négociation qu'il y aurait un
autre a effectivement des terroristes et
les autorités maliennes alors que nous
sommes censés protéger le mali comment
peut-on imaginer
ce marché de dupes dont la france a été
pas victime mais ce qui montre parce que
le terme serait finalement sommes un peu
trop gentil pour les autorités
françaises ont c'est un marché de dupes
parce que nos autorités n'ont pas été à
la hauteur de la situation elle se sont
fait berner voilà et aujourd'hui quand
le gouvernement cherche à à dire qui
n'est pas partie prenante dans cette
affaire en réalité il sait très bien que
tout ceci va revenir sur lui c'était une
catastrophe en réalité d'imaginer quand
même la situation de tous nos militaires
français au mali depuis huit ans de
leurs familles de cette situation
où on a été le dise le disent pas
officiellement mais ils le disent
évidemment on le sait c'est terrible
quel est le sens de l'engagement de la
france au mali dans ces conditions là
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
situation qui si vous voulez qui dépasse
l'entendement
la france ne représente plus rien dans
cette histoire et c'est dramatique moi
ça me fait mal quoi comment nombreux
français il faut il est temps qu'on
revienne aux sujets principaux de la
france reprenne sa place dans le concert
des nations et dise les choses pourquoi
de sa position et on arrête de faire la
communication et des opérations de
publicité pour le gouvernement qui
tourne effectivement très mal est là
avec cette affaire est prôné un bis et
bien c'est s'est à nouveau et c'est le
signe pas ce qui s'est passé en réalité
blaise à kananga et vous partagez ces
diagnostics à travers cette affaire pour
le moins rocambolesque ça interroge
clairement sur ses relations entre la
france
le mali
non moi je crois qu'il n'y a pas une
volonté
manifeste et vraiment c'est pas par
gaieté de coeur que le mali cherche à
négocier ou à interroger les différentes
parties c'est pas pour moi ce n'est pas
une manière de berne au barça est qui et
qui nous sommes ici
pour longtemps en tout cas j'espère mais
c'est en désespoir de cause que ces gens
essayent de trouver d'autres tristes
parce que
le mali aujourd'hui est sûre militarisé
yahia il ya des nations-unies à la
france et à la cedeao il ya il ya tout
le monde qui est là qui sont là bas mais
en réalité quand vous venez dans des les
résultats c'est vraiment des milliers de
villages qui sont ou ont été effacées de
la tarte de du pays il ya aujourd'hui
plus de 1600 écoles fermées bon quand on
voit interne des résultats c'est à dire
que le faire nous pouvons quand même
saluer la mémoire effectivement de ces
femmes et ces hommes qui ont perdu la
vie en essayant de protéger d'autres
personnes mais quand on regarde les ré
les résultats de toutes celles de toutes
ses interventions et on les gardait un
peu la chronologie de l'histoire vous
assure que c'est pas désespoir de cause
que les gens essaient de chercher
d'autres solutions mais je ne crois pas
que disait le gouvernement at-il
certaine volonté d'écarter qui que ce
soit mais ils sont aussi aujourd'hui
dans l'ouverture de pouvoir vraiment
trouver une solution par tous les moyens
parce que c'est impossible quand vous
prenez par exemple le centre du mali moi
je viens du pays d'euros alors on ne
peut même pas se déplacer de ces vallées
à bandiagara donc on a tout perdu moi
qui vous parle d'aujourd'hui j'ai des
proches qui ont été tués il ya des
villages qui ont été carrément incendie
est maintenant là l'insécurité montre
jusqu'aux jusqu'à six ou sept années que
la région de ségou à 2,5 km de bamako où
on est en train de brûler et toutes les
récoltes même les machines agricoles
nous on a on n'a pas de choix on ne sait
pas comment faire on ne sait pas à quel
saint se vouer donc je ne crois pas que
et de manière intentionnelle il ya une
volonté d'écarter la race mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui là où nous sommes toutes
les solutions sont les bienvenus pour
vraiment
arrêter cette hémorragie qui n'a que
trop duré est-ce donc en ce qui concerne
s'occuper tron est aussi bon moi je m'en
tiens un peu à la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
l'article 13 qui dit que toute personne
a le droit à la mobilité etc mais moi
aussi je crois que la solution aurait
été de pouvoir l'encadrer et non
l'enfermer parce que l'on a horreur de
du tabou donc on a tendance à
transcender l'interview donc mais la
dame au mali depuis masse donc je ne
vois pas pourquoi est-ce que c'est
maintenant d'ailleurs que cette question
est soulevée c'est bien la question
justement con con qu'on se pose et qui
interroge en réagissant sur ce que
disait drissa canada bon moi je trouve
qu'il ya du vent est évidemment dans ce
qui vient d'être dit c'est sûr que si le
mali aujourd'hui a décidé de prendre son
destin en main c'était un peu quand même
le but au départ de l'opération serval
et de l'opération barkan qui a suivi
c'était de faire en sorte qu'une fois la
situation militaire et sécuritaire
rétabli ce qu'elle a été dans un premier
temps et bien le mali reprennent les
mails et les comores les lits les rênes
de son destin et s'affirmer et comment
malheureusement ce qu'on remarque c'est
que dans dont m sous l'autorité du
président précédent premier ministre ib
cas et bien le mali est parti à vau de
l'eau le mali est devenu un état failli
aujourd'hui je pense que dans la boue
une grande explication une grande des
grandes explications du coup d'état
militaire
comment diriger par assimiler aux états
a été justement de de mettre un terme
justement à 7 à cette dérive de
commandes du pays et au fait que le pays
connaisse justement une véritable de
commande un véritable démantèlement le
mali est un état failli le mettre le
mali est un état où les comment
l'autorité ne s'exerce plus dans
certaines provinces où il ya des zones
entières qui sont tombées aux mains de
bandes armées parce qu'il ya pas que les
djihadistes on parle des djihadistes
mais il ya aussi énormément de commandes
d' opportuniste de gens qui qui voilà
qui pillent des régions entières et et
donc les déplacements de population les
comment les affrontements ethniques ça a
été ça a été l'explosion donc
aujourd'hui le mali essaye de négocier
avec un certain nombre de groupes moi je
pense que c'est une c'est un véritable
progrès je pense qu'il ya ils font kill
kill que ça continue il faut que le mali
rétablisse les services publics dans
certains endroits vous avez moi j'ai
beaucoup de passes et de temps avec
comment avec les soldats français au
mali dans le cadre de l'opération barkan
vous avez des villes comme une d'elimane
par exemple à côté de de ménaka ça fait
deux ans quasiment qui a pas de présence
militaire parce que les djihadistes ont
attaqué une fois et que la garnison est
parti donc si vous voulez il faut que
l'état malien se réaffirme c'est ce que
je pense que ce que les autorités
maliennes ont la volonté maintenant sur
le cap et ronan on peut pas dire cette
personne a le droit à la mobilité quand
on sait que ce droit à la mobilité a
provoqué la libération de 200 jihadistes
et je rappelle que ces 210 à dist pour
les arrêter pour les mettre en prison un
certain nombre de noces de nos forces et
de nos soldats sont morts pour ça donc
voilà donc c'est pas possible de faire
ça cette personne si elle désirait
rester au début elle aurait très bien pu
rester avec ces groupes personne ne
l'aurait empêché son fils a alerté
l'opinion souvenez vous des articles de
presse ma mère est en train de mourir
etc etc et on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui
ces gens qui sont irresponsables
il le fils non seulement la compagne
pour qu'elle revienne si elle ne disait
désirait pas partir et bien que quelques
elle y reste au mali voilà c'est tout
jean paul garraud le mot de la fin
oui bah écoutez moi je rejoins ce qui
vient d'être dit je dirai simplement en
conclusion que madame petro n'a
effectivement risque d'être à nouveau
aux tâches
active et bien surtout qu'on ne prennent
aucun risque pour la libérer mais
vraiment aucun risque et que nos soldats
ne prennent aucun risque si jamais elle
venait à nouveau à être captif parce que
je me pose même la question de savoir si
elle était vraiment otages et je me
demande aussi en ce qui concerne le
double jeu semble-t-il qui a été menée
par son fils de ce site une sombre
affaire et je crois que la france n'a
rien à faire avec le cap et rose merci
beaucoup en tout cas tous les trois jean
paul garraud régis le sommier drissa
can't buy un merci d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france
à six mois de la présidentielle un
nouveau sondage place emmanuel macron en
tête du premier tour devant eric zemmour
et marine le pen le président sortant se
qualifierait pour le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle devant le
polémiste identitaire suivi par la
candidate du rn sondage publié
aujourd'hui par harris interactive pour
challenges et l approche de ce scrutin
ait bien fait bien etonant certains
médias firmin qu'il y aurait un lien
supposé entre eric zemmour et moscou à
l'origine de cette idée l'hebdomadaire
l'ops une révélation en forme d'intox
reprise par la presse internationale
les explications de katia technique
la présidentielle approche et avec elle
les prédictions de madame irma et les
uns fox de bonimenteur pullulent dans un
bruit de lavabos qui se vide la dernière
en date selon l'ops le kremlin zemmour
même pas au conditionnel mais aussi bien
les analyses des géostratège proche du
kremlin que la tonalité de la presse
contrôlée par le pouvoir russe laisse
peu de doute sur le choix d'un pouvoir
russe qui commençaient à désespérer de
marine le pen pour poutine l'espoir
c'est zemmour est maintenant dans notre
grand horoscope je vous propose de
passer aux prévisions des capricornes
pourquoi l'homme s'est-il certain que le
kremlin votre humour le journaliste
s'appuie sur un obscur médias qui
dénaturent l'analyse d'une parlementaire
elena pamina issu du parti au pouvoir
russie unie
le tout sur le blog d'un prime time que
personne ne connaît et les nappes à nina
parlerai au nom de vladimir poutine
selon l'ops voilà deux ans elle a créé
un film tanks roux strates qualifié par
l'ops de boîte à outils du kremlin en
réalité sur le site d'euros strates et
n'a pas nina se contente de décrire le
chroniqueur français et ses idées et
elle conclut son article par une
précaution verbale dans le cas d'une
victoire du polémiste il est possible
que l'on assiste à une alliance de
moscou paris et berlin qui affrontera
les anglo saxons emmenée par les états
unis et la grande bretagne on est loin
de l'annoncé d'un soutien de vladimir
poutine mais penchons nous sur cette
influence intake les articles du site
affiche entre 38 et 150 vu chacun dans
sa version anglaise avec une moyenne de
quelques milliers de vues sur les
articles écrits en russe comme un bon
blog sur les selles de cheval ou les
fourchettes à huîtres en comparaison le
monde affiche plus de 300 millions de
pages vues en septembre 2021 cette
supposée de boîte à outils du kremlin
semble un peu rouillé l'autre source de
l'os dans ce dossier et le media desk
russie qui lui aussi réplique l'article
2 roues strates entre autres
élucubrations on apprend qu'eric zemmour
pourrait entamer une guerre civile
appelons hollywood ils pourraient même
demander aux forces russes de faire de
l'ordre en france face à une révolte des
banlieues consécutives à ces mesures
contre l'immigration d'ex crussy est
dirigée par galia ackerman qui demandait
qu'on refuse la licence de diffusion rt
france et par le haut fonctionnaire
nicolas tenzer dans la rue sauf il y n'a
d'égal que l'amour qu'il porte à rt
france un organe de propagande dépendant
du kremlin n'est pas un organe de presse
ceux qui acceptent de parler sur russia
today sont soit des complices du régime
et donc de ces crimes soient des
personnes qu'ils consentent un pli
comment être manipulé par lui tout cela
pourrait n'être que comique si ces
fadaises n'avait pas été immédiatement
relayée dans des articles du monde
entier de l'australie à la grande
bretagne en passant par la pologne et
aussi par la députée européenne nathalie
l'oiseau pas de doute moscou vote et
moore mais aussi encore un peu le pen
aucun doute a contrario des chercheurs
sur la stratégie d'influencé
informationnel russe en france pourtant
très critique du kremlin honteux même
relevé l'inanité de l'article de l'ops
bon je vais reprendre point par point ce
qui ne va pas dans cet article et la
liste est longue ça me met en rogne
carey dax chef puisse laisser publier ce
genre de chose d'autant plus dans ce
contexte préélectoral ils font le jeu du
pouvoir russe qui doit se réjouir
d'avancé de voir son nombre planer sur
la campagne pour 3000 signes publié par
un think tank inconnu je vois déjà la
vidéo triomphante de rt france qui va
suivre tout content qu'on parle d'eux
alors oui voilà la vidéo mais nous ne
sommes pas particulièrement ravi que
l'on parle de nous de plus en tant que
média de propagande russe à destination
de l'étranger selon la logique du
journaliste de l'ops puisque eric
zemmour serait le candidat de vladimir
poutine nous devrions donc déroulé le
tapis rouge au chroniqueur mais ce sont
les médias français qui s'en charge avec
une certaine insistance seul marianne et
les échos cite son nom - que nous
rappelons avant que d'autres médias si m
kurt et france n'est pas partisane et
n'appuie aucun candidat dans l'hexagone
la chaîne se fera le relais de tous les
participants à la présidentielle quel
que soit leur bord politique comme
durant chaque élection et promis on ne
vous dira pas l'horoscope là qui dit et
pour en parler pour élargir ce débat
nous sommes avec alexis poulain
éditorialistes bonsoir alexis alors le
travail des journalistes a été bâclée
dans cette histoire où il ya un petit
procès d'intention là dedans non
clairement c'est pas du travail de
journaliste c'est un travail d'
influence on va dire puisque à le
travail journalistique que demande de
contrôler et vérifier les sources et
plusieurs sources est d'avoir plusieurs
sources qui vont être concordantes la
recherche de la vérité c'est compliqué
alors quand on s'appuie sur une note de
blog ou un tweet pour dire voilà ce qui
se passe voilà où on en est on n'appelle
pas ça dure et c'est du buzz c'est
plutôt un jeu d' influence ce qu'on
retrouve sur les médias sociaux mais on
peut pas appeler ça un travail
journalistique
alors les faits qu'il nie aux ans c'est
long mutations du moment pourtant chez
les journalistes
père de la morale et les politiques
français principalement d'ailleurs dans
la majorité oui alors effectué aux on
voit bien que c'est un gouvernement
obnubilé en général par la communication
le budget communication qui a explosé en
2020 doublé jusqu'à 28 millions 30
millions de rallonge pour 2021 le
gouvernement nous dit que c'est à cause
de la crise du coc vide mais il ya plein
de campagne sur la laïcité sur les 1000
premiers jours de la paternité etc la
maternité bref c'est un gouvernement qui
fait d'abord de la com et très peu de
politique donc il veut contrôler toute
cette communication parce que vous le
savez très bien beaucoup de faits que
nous viennent en partie de certains
états qui veulent faire passer des
messages pour orienter la population et
c'est donc on est là avec les
commissions fait qu tous comme la
commission brauner dans le finalement
qui a le droit de dire la vérité qui a
le droit aussi de labelliser la vérité
certains sites ou ong parlent même de
vouloir labellisé certains médias c'est
le cas de rt france sur les réseaux
sociaux puisque on est un des rares à
avoir ce label mais qui a financé par la
russie est pas le cas pour france 24 où
la bbc ou qu'un plein d'autres médias
qui sont financés par des états donc il
ya une vraie volonté de non pas lutter
contre l'effet que nous mais d'éviter
qu'ils aient des sources d'information
discordantes puisque la parole divine
doit devenir de du pc jupiter hier à
l'elysée en gros c'est un peu ça et est
d'ailleurs la commission brenner a été
moquée puisqu'un des membres avaient été
a vu quelques ennuis avec l'ordre des
médecins puisqu'il avait lui-même fait
quelques faits que nous pour attaquer un
collègue donc on n'est pas à l'abri de
n'importe quel fait que nous en réalité
et cette obsession des faits que nous en
dit long aussi sur la fabrique de
l'information parce que c'est difficile
effectivement de faire un travail d'
enquête un travail journalistique ça
prend du temps or dans cette immédiateté
permanente des réseaux sociaux on
cherche toujours le buzz on cherche
toujours la formation la plus rapide le
scoop est souvent et parfois
malheureusement on va tomber sur des
informations erronées force est de
constater que les mots russie et zemmour
est bien ensemble ça marche plutôt bien
pour faire comme vous l'avez dit du buzz
mais aussi du bashing parce que
finalement il ya d'autres candidats qui
se positionne en faveur d'une nouvelle
politique étrangère avec la russie
écouter
il nous faut aujourd'hui changer de
logique avec la russie de monsieur
poutine je pense qu'il est urgent de
renouer un dialogue politique de haut
niveau et pas seulement des entretiens
téléphoniques avec le président poutine
et xavier bertrand n'est pas le seul
d'ailleurs certains membres de la
majorité aussi pense qu'il est important
d'avoir un rapport avec la russie or le
problème du logiciel mac ronis tu sais
qu'il est extrêmement européen par
essence et il ya une russophobie il faut
pas se leurrer de par la façon dont
l'otan est organisé les frontières avec
les pays que des pays baltes notamment
qui ont très peur du voisin russe or on
le voit bien avec la crise de l'énergie
la russie et clés sur le prix du gaz on
ne peut pas faire une europe qui
fonctionne sans un partenaire de
confiance comme la russie donc il ya un
vrai problème avec ça et clairement
c'est taper sur zemmour taper sur la
russie en disant que voilà la russie a
choisi un candidat ce serait un peu gros
et d'ailleurs l'europe n'est pas en
reste puisque raphaël glucksmann est
aujourd'hui partie à taiwan dans une
mission d'observation contre les
ingérences des états étrangers alors
c'est assez croquignolet ce qu'un
puisque c'est les députés européens qui
vont en mission d'observation sur
l'ingérence bon pourquoi pas mais ça
fait partie un peu de ces valeurs vous
savez la démocratie libérale les valeurs
des états de droit qui sont des mots
valises en réalité pour dire on ne sait
pas ce que font les autres en réalité
c'est tout à fait sujet à discussion
merci beaucoup alexis poulain merci
d'avoir été avec nous
et focus sur le couple franco-allemand à
deux mois de la présidence française de
l'union européenne justement la
chancelière allemande sortante angela
merkel a effectué aujourd'hui sa
dernière visite protocolaire sur le sol
hexagonal près de dijon une réception
avec elle les honneurs à présent quelles
seront les nouvelles relations
franco-allemandes passe merkel on voit
ce avaient quadrillé affrontements
d'ici quelques semaines
olaf scholz sera le nouvel interlocuteur
du président français et des membres de
son futur gouvernement de coalition
pourrait bien constituer un frein à la
bonne entente franco allemande
parmi les principales craintes le fdp
parti libéral démocrate et son leader
christian lindner car si en marche et le
parti allemand son partenaire au
parlement européen des divergences
politiques sont bien présentes l'europe
sociale chère à emmanuel macron n'est
pas du goût du fdp qui prône plutôt la
discipline budgétaire et entend bien
peser sur la future révision des
critères de maastricht qui régissent
l'économie de la zone euro mais le fdp
n'est pas totalement fermée sur toutes
les questions en février dernier d'abord
opposés au plan de relance économique de
l'ue eux les cinq représentants du parti
au parlement européen votée finalement
faveur des textes autre point d'entente
avec emmanuel macron une europe de la
défense
les libéraux démocrates sont partisans
d'une force européenne indépendante des
américains
reste à savoir maintenant quelle place
prendra le fdp au sein du gouvernement
et si la formation de christian lindner
choisira de conserver des positions
ouvertes une chose est sûre la relation
entre alliés français et allemands en
dépendra en grande partie
la prolongation du pass sanitaire
antique hobbit jusqu'en juillet prochain
plus que jamais d'actualité le texte est
aujourd'hui en examen à l'assemblée
nationale avant de repasser demain par
le sénat l'ultime vote aura lieu après
demain au palais bourbon alors que le
but était sénateur s'écharpent sur la
prorogation du texte controversé et les
bacs et continue d'être musclé comme en
attestent ses réactions micro de
sébastien dufour
les positions entre l'opposition de
l'assemblée nationale le sénat d'une
part et celle de la majorité du
gouvernement sont totalement
inconciliables et pour cause le
gouvernement veut totalement en jambes
et 8 mois de contrôle démocratique veut
nous faire voter aujourd'hui début
novembre un texte qui pourrait continuer
à produire des effets jusqu'à l'été à
l'ami et et 2022 c'est tout à fait
inconcevable donc que le gouvernement
ait les moyens de travailler bien sûr
n'importe quel gouvernement a besoin
d'outils pour lutter contre la copie de
mai mais pas sans le contrôle
démocratique qui est la contrepartie
deux de ses pouvoirs alors je ne dirais
pas que c'est un déni de démocratie mais
je dirais que ce pouvoir est autoritaire
c'est à dire qu'il ya une certaine
arrogance et une un refus finalement de
discuter et de se remettre en cause
forcément c'est eux qui savent bien
faire
moi je pense qu'on est plus intelligent
à plusieurs avec plusieurs idées
différentes qu'ont les confrontent et
c'est comme ça qu'on avance vers ce
qu'il ya de mieux et en général quand on
dit que c'est moi le plus malin et le
plus intelligent ça pose problème et
lundi prochain la rentrée sera marquée
par le retour du port du masque dans 39
départements avec un taux d'incidence
supérieur à 50 pour cent mille habitants
le gouvernement se voit obliger de
rétablir certaines restrictions on voit
ça avec amaya soul et il était redouté
par des milliers de français le masque
est de retour dans les écoles
à partir de la semaine prochaine et de
la rentrée scolaire dans les
départements où le taux d'incidence
c'est malheureusement re stabiliser au
dessus de 50 pour cent mille habitants
le protocole scolaire va repasser du
niveau 1 au niveau 2 c'est à dire que le
masque va à nouveau être rendu
obligatoire pour les enfants des écoles
concernées ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que cela concerne pour lundi
prochain 39 départements 22 départements
étaient encore concernés par cette
mesure ils seront désormais 61 dans tout
l'hexagone
la règle fixe l'obligation du port du
masque à l'école dès lors que le taux
d'incidence dépasse les 50 pour cent
mille habitants pendant cinq jours
consécutifs
du côté des syndicats le retour de cette
mesure dans les établissements est
accueillie avec beaucoup de réserve pour
certains
le retour du port du masque va être
compliqué parce que ça va créer de
l'incompréhension chez les élèves et
chez les parents ces allers-retours
risque de créer de l'instabilité et de
l'insécurité dans les écoles pour
d'autres elle permet de montrer
l'exemple en matière de lutte contre le
coc vide
ça peut susciter de l'incompréhension
sans doute mais c'est aussi notre rôle
celui de l'ensemble des personnels de
l'éducation mais aussi du gouvernement
d'expliquer qu'on n'est pas sortis
encore de cette pandémie
l'augmentation des cas restent moins
alarmante en france que dans d'autres
pays européens
aux pays-bas la flambée des cas a obligé
les autorités à remettre en place de
nombreuses restrictions liées aux covit
19 aux états unis à présent les 5-11 ans
vaccinée contre le coc vie 19 17
semaines l'accord a été donné hier par
les autorités sanitaires américaines
on en parle avec notre correspondante au
m'abonner à washington bonsoir thomas 28
millions d'enfants concernés donc par
cette nouvelle campagne de vaccination
thomas
oui et les injections ont déjà commencé
pour les enfants de cette tranche d'âge
de 5 à 11 ans avec des doses qui sont
différentes que celles qui sont
administrés aux adultes un tiers du
dosage et trois semaines entre les deux
injections alors les autorités
américaines s'étaient préparés en
réalité déjà depuis plusieurs jours
puisque des doses avec notamment étaient
disposés dans des cliniques pédiatriques
et vous rappeler que c'est d'abord
l'agencé américaine des médicaments qui
la semaine dernière avait donné son
autorisation pour la vaccination pour
les enfants donc âgés de 5 à 11 ans une
décision qui a été ensuite approuvé ce
mardi par la cie d'ici le centre de
prévention et de lutte contre les
maladies un tournant qui est salué par
le président américain qui voit une
étape majeure dans la lutte contre le
coc vite 19 aux états unis écouter
cela permettra aux parents de mettre fin
à des mois d'inquiétude et d'anxiété
pour leurs enfants et de réduire la
mesure dans laquelle les enfants
transmettent le virus aux autres c'est
un grand pas en avant pour notre nation
dans notre combat pour vaincre le virus
alors dès aujourd'hui des parents ont
conduit leurs enfants dans des centres
de vaccination selon une étude des
autorités américaines 57 % des parents
interrogés à disent qu'ils allaient
probablement ou très certainement
conduire leurs enfants afin qu'ils se
fassent vacciner on a donc pu voir
aujourd'hui dans les médias américains
ces images d'injection administré à des
enfants et des parents donc à rassurer
que leur progéniture puisse enfin être
protégés contre le coc vie 19 écouter
ces témoignages
je pourrais plus rien qu'en pensant à ce
mouvement ce que nous la touche depuis
si longtemps
pour que nos enfants puissent retrouver
le sentiment de vivre normalement
on n'arrête pas de dire que ça va aller
pour le mieux n'est ce pas l'allemande a
parcouru du chemin depuis le début de la
pandémie et je pense qu'il est très
important que tout le monde sache que
nous sommes là pour veiller les uns sur
les autres afin de retrouver une vie
normale et la meilleure façon d'y
arriver c'est en me protégeant alors
évidemment il ya encore une certaine
forme d'inquiétude des craintes de la
part de certains parents qui disent
redouter d'éventuels effets secondaires
sur leurs enfants les autorités
sanitaires américaines se veulent
rassurantes particulièrement sur les cas
de myocardite qu'elle estime très rare
il faut préciser que cette autorisation
ne concerne pour le moment que le vaccin
kaiser l'entreprise à mener des essais
cliniques sur des milliers d'enfants et
se vante d'une efficacité à
97% contre les formes symptomatiques sur
cette tranche d'âge donc de 5 à 11 ans
et pour remercier les enfants qui ont
participé à ces essais cliniques
l'entreprise pfizer a publié une vidéo
sur son compte youtube où ses enfants
sont présentés comme des super héros
dotés de super pouvoirs écouter
[Musique]
voilà pour cette communication enfantine
de la part de pfizer dont chacun jugera
la pertinence en tout cas avec cette
nouvelle étape dans la campagne de
vaccination les autorités américaines
espèrent restreindre la restreindre la
circulation du coc vie 19 dans le pays
même si des études récentes ont montré
que les écoles ne constituait pas
véritablement des foyers de
contamination
abonnés merci vous restez avec nous
parce qu'on va aller plus loin avec un
autre invité bruno me garbade chef du
service réanimation de l'hôpital
lariboisière grand défenseur de l'as de
la vaccination un bon soir bruno meyer
vannes merci d'être avec nous joe biden
qui déclarent aujourd'hui que cela
permettra donc aux parents de mettre fin
à des mois d'inquiétude et réduira la
transmission du virus par les enfants on
a vu la satisfaction de de nombreux
parents américains c'était nécessaire
pour vous de franchir ce pas sans état
d'âme
écoutez tout d'abord les études
scientifiques
pour le moment non publiées il faut le
dire en tout cas fourni aux autorités
sanitaires
heather et modern à effectuer sur
plusieurs milliers d'enfants semble
montrer que le vaccin est parfaitement
efficace et très bien toléré alors c'est
vrai qu'à ce jour
on va dire le nombre total d'enfants
finalement ayant reçu le vaccin reste
encore limitée donc on peut pas affirmer
définitivement
notamment en termes d'effets secondaires
rares que ceux ci n'existe pas par
contre évidemment
c'est un pas encourageant pour permettre
à la vaccination des plus jeunes car à
nouveau cette tranche d'âge pour le
moment est la seule non vaccinés et
malheureusement le virus circule
essentiellement parmi les avec des
personnes non vaccinées
l'institut pasteur estime par exemple
qu'à l'occasion du rebond de l'épidémie
que nous allons observer cet hiver et
bien 50% des contaminations auront lieu
chez les enfants or toute personne non
vaccinés risque d'abord de faire une
forme grave de la maladie il faut savoir
qu'en france aujourd'hui environ 50
enfants sont hospitalisés pour une forme
plus sérieuse de la commune 19 et que
les enfants sont malgré tout exposé aux
risques de kovy de long est désormais
des études très sérieuses montrent là
l'entrée du virus du moins
l'inflammation de certaines régions du
cerveau en cas d'infection y compris
bénigne qui peut être à l'origine
d'ennui prolongée et bruno megaman ya
aussi ce variant anglais qui se propage
plus rapidement
chez les enfants avec une augmentation
des hospitalisations
particulièrement sur les enfants
américains ce qui explique peut-être
moins de scepticisme là bas et un
accueil plus favorable à la à la
vaccination
alors vous avez raison il ya deux
différences importantes entre la france
et les états unis tout d'abord les
enfants américains souffrent avec une
prévalence plus importante de
comorbidité notamment d'obésité et on
sait par expérience que la cobi 19
atteint préférentiellement les personnes
obèses et il résulte en une forme un peu
plus grave de la maladie la deuxième
différence c'est que la couverture
vaccinale aux états unis est bien moins
bonne qu'en france aujourd'hui en france
environ
76 % de la population
éligible à la vaccination est doublement
vacciner ses 20 points de plus qu'aux
états unis et donc évidemment le fait de
vacciner les enfants aux etats-unis
contribuera quelque part à réduire la
circulation du virus donc à protéger
indirectement les personnes plus âgées
et un risque non maxime thomas comment
réagissent les autorités locales à
l'ouverture de la vaccination des
enfants on précise aux états unis c'est
important de le dire qu'à part je crois
en l'état de new york il n'y a pas de
passes annie terre donc c'est une
oblique ce n'est pas une obligation qui
dit pas son nom comme ça peut l'être
vécu en france mais voilà une
proposition de vaccination
oui alors beaucoup de localités beaucoup
d'élus se sont félicités de cette
possibilité de vacciner les enfants
comme je vous le disais tout a déjà été
mise en place en réalité depuis quelques
jours pour permettre cette vaccination
mais il ya quand même des contestations
assez local on parle beaucoup on a
beaucoup parlé dans votre émission de
l'état du texas et de la floride qui
sont un peu à la pointe justement de
cette contestation contre les
obligations que ce soit en ce qui
concerne le port du masque en ce qui
concerne les obligations de vaccination
est d'ailleurs le gouverneur de l'état
de floride il y a quelques jours avant
que cette autorisation ne soit accordée
avait déjà affirmé publiquement qu'il
n'y aurait jamais d'obligations de
vaccination pour les enfants scolarisés
dans l'état de floride on sait qu'il est
déjà opposée au masque obligatoire dans
les écoles il veut laisser la liberté
aux parents parce qu'en réalité aux
états unis le débat au-delà de
s'articuler autour de pro ou anti
vaccins s'articule surtout autour de la
notion de liberté et que ce soit le
gouverneur du texas où le gouverneur de
floride ils veulent laisser la liberté
justement aux parents de décider ce
qu'il souhaite faire pour ce qui
concerne leurs enfants on a aussi vu
récemment des mouvements de
contestations y compris à new york que
vous en parliez ou des pompiers
notamment sont en arrêt maladie en grand
nombre depuis plusieurs jours justement
pour s'opposer à l'obligation de
vaccination il est intéressant de noter
que le maire de new york qui vient tout
juste d'être élu à d'ailleurs dit que ce
serait un dossier sur lequel il allait
se pencher assez rapidement bruno
m'égare ban c'est vrai qu'à cinq ans on
est vraiment encore un petit bout d'chou
ya de nombreux parents qui sont pas
forcément anti vaccins y compris en
france qui seraient extrêmement inquiets
l'idée de les faire vacciner clairement
je vous pose la question est-ce qu'on a
suffisamment de recul pour prendre ce
risque
alors je dirais on va dire aujourd'hui
je suis d'accord avec vous le recul est
peut-être encore on va dire minimaliste
il est vrai que je ne crois pas que les
autorités sanitaires en arrive à décider
d'une obligation de la vaccination y
compris aux états unis pour les enfants
de 5 à 11 ans à linverse très
progressivement et bien on va accumuler
des données parce que
que ce soit aux états unis à cuba en
israël un nombre croissant d'enfants de
5 à 11 ans vont être vaccinés et donc on
va pouvoir voir un peu comme ça a été
fait chez l'adulte et bien les risques
de complications notamment de
complication rare vous avez parlé de
myocardite on peut parler peut-être de
l'inflammation multi systémique
éventuellement de problèmes de
plaquettes s'il y en avait et donc on va
pouvoir voir ces risques là à mon sens
ils seront très faibles mais on va
pouvoir mieux mesurer la balance
bénéfice risque avant évidemment
d'entrer dans une campagne de
vaccination plus systématique des
enfants moi je suis convaincu qu'à terme
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire y
compris chez les enfants car c'est
malheureusement la solution unique pour
pouvoir sortir définitivement
de cette épidémie mais aujourd'hui je
suis tout à fait d'accord il faut encore
être un tout petit peu plus prudent les
données des laboratoires sont
extrêmement encourageantes le vaccin est
parfaitement efficace et surtout est
très bien toléré d'après leurs données
il faut encore attendre une augmentation
du nombre d'enfants vaccinés il faut
savoir d'ailleurs qu'en france environ
vingt mille enfants de 0 à 11 à 11 ans
ont été déjà vaccinés car c'étaient des
enfants un risque de faire des formes
graves de la maladie et chez ces enfants
en tout cas il n'a pas été signalé
d'effets secondaires de l'état
donc ça qu'on sent désormais au moment
une révélation fait beaucoup parler sur
ce même laboratoire aux états unis
où il s'agit d'une publication qui est
parue dans le british medical journal
qui donne la parole qui donne le
témoignage d'une ancienne directrice
régionale d'une entreprise qui s'appelle
vente à vias est une entreprise qui a
été chargé à partir du mois d'août 2020
de mener des essais cliniques au tour
justement du vaccin fader ça se passe
dans l'état du texas et donc cette
ancienne directrice régionale explique
que de nombreux problèmes se sont
produits lors de ces essais par exemple
des manquements dans les essais censé
être réalisé à l'aveuglé qui finalement
ne l'était pas des consignes des
employés pour modifier des données des
protocoles non respecté un manque de
suivi des effets indésirables chez
certains patients ou encore l'absence de
tests pcr pour justement des patients
ayant contracté des symptômes ducobu 19
alors cet ancien employé avait
rapidement avertit l'agencé américaine
des médicaments la f10 est mais elle n'a
pas été écouté par sa hiérarchie il a
même été licencié et depuis d'autres
employés semblent confirmer ces méthodes
toujours auprès du british medical
journal
alors il faut noter que ces accusations
concernent un laboratoire au texas qui
couvre environ 1000 patients sur
lesquels 44 mille personnes qui ont
constitué ces essais cliniques pour
l'élaboration du vaccin weiser alors il
ya évidemment une question sur le
contrôle des autorités sanitaires par
sur ces essais cliniques puisque sur les
153 sites où se sont déroulés les essais
cliniques aux états unis seuls neuf ont
été contrôlés par la f10 est et sur ses
neufs qui bien il n'y a pas la fameuse
entreprise vend tabia qui est basé au
texas cela pose donc la question des
moyens mis en oeuvre par les autorités
sanitaires américaines pour contrôler et
pour faire toute la transparence sur les
essais cliniques qui ont été faits dans
le cadre du vaccin de pfizer bruno mes
gamins on a souvent eu d'occasion
ensemble voilà vous avez fait des face à
face avec justement des gens qui
n'avaient pas confiance on ce vaccin ce
type d'histoire alors elles sont
peut-être isolé mais tout de même ce
n'est pas de nature à restaurer la
confiance qu'est ce que ça vous évoque
quand vous entendez ce type justement de
deux récits
je suis d'accord avec vous effectivement
lorsqu'on met en place des essais
thérapeutiques avec l'urgence que l'on
connaît
lié à l'épidémie il peut y avoir
malheureusement des dysfonctionnements
il peut éventuellement y avoir des
personnes qui ne triche en tout cas tout
cela nécessite des contrôles à ce jour
je pense que si les autorités
américaines de la f10 est agréé
que ce vaccin pouvait être utilisé chez
les enfants c'est qu'ils ont regardé de
très près l'ensemble des résultats et
qu'il n'y avait pas de on va dire de
doute quant à l'exactitude des données
fournies par le laboratoire il faut en
fait savoir que les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques fournissent au fur et à
mesure leurs résultats aux données
aux eaux aux autorités sanitaires que ce
soit aux états unis en europe et même en
france la nsm regarde de façon très
régulière les résultats
donc je crois qu'il faut quand même
faire confiance aux autorités sanitaires
en tout cas pour l'adulte aujourd'hui
plus de
5 millions 5 milliards pardon de
personnes sur terre ont reçu des doses
de vaccin est donc évidemment s'il y
avait eu des problèmes il serait apparu
merci beaucoup en tout cas bruno home &
garden thomas bonnin en direct de
washington merci d'avoir été avec nous
restez avec nous dans quelques secondes
nous parlerons du nucléaire dans notre
rubrique qu'en pensent les français ce
soir nous irons à la rencontre du maire
de fessenheim un an après la fermeture
de sa centrale nucléaire
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure du genre dont deux
singes le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descende des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous sommes
cousins germains maternelle qui était
bretonne me disais si toi tu descends du
sage mois sur rampe a révélé nous un
secret vous en avez mangé du mam où je
me trouve à fouiller en sibérie et puis
un beau matin dans le trou que j'avais
commencé à creuser je trouve que les
troupes comme ce quelque chose de bien
et des grands filaments je suis étonnée
je râle je dirais que ce sont des
collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos
[Musique]
de cuir des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
c'est que leur cerveau artarit c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes mais ce qui nous alertent nous
c'est la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix exact mais ça veut dire
que l'hygiène de vie notre facteur de
risque numéro un on a plutôt un système
de soins qu'ils aient accès fléché sur
le traitement de la maladie soupçon
diagnostic et le traitement et non pas
sur la prévention et on aimerait un
système très curatif 1 c'est essentiel
d'avoir l'information pour pas subir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la communication des modèles macro prêts
à des jeunes via twitter instagram
victhom est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont il se désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus quand on est justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour moissac hommes
politiques personnelles est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme si son travail en notre nom
pour nous aider dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire nucléaire stop ou encore le
débat est ouvert ce soir à l'occasion
d'un coq 26 vous pouvez réagir sur le
compte et les gammes rt france qu'il en
est encore temps et dans notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français on ira à la
rencontre du maire de fessenheim un an
après la fermeture de sa centrale
nucléaire l'élu dit avoir été privé d'un
véritable poumon économique à
[Musique]
la coop 26 se poursuit donc à glasgow
jour 3 aujourd'hui 450 secteur financier
se sont engagés à atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 des
banques assurances et gestionnaires
d'actifs de 45 pays en ont fait la
promesse au total 112 mille milliards
d'euros seront débloqués un engagement
qui laisse sur leur faim les
organisations non gouvernementales
elle demande une règle claire et écrites
pour mettre fin à l'expansion des
énergies fossiles et parmi ces énergies
justement le nucléaire dans notre
rubrique en pensent les français on vous
emmène ce soir à fessenheim qui a vu sa
centrale affair médias renom depuis le
maire de cette commune du haut-rhin
accuse le coup parlant de la perte du
poumon économique de toute une région un
reportage signé estelle farge et renault
parquet
je suis à fessenheim d'ailleurs assez
gris il y à la centrale nucléaire qui a
fermé ses portes l'année dernière
c'était une promesse de campagne de
françois hollande mais c'est emmanuel
macron qu'il l'a réalisé le chef de
l'état a récemment remis le débat du
nucléaire sur la table avec son plan
france de mai 30 un revirement que ne
comprend pas le maire de fessenheim
claude brender on va tout de suite allé
à sa rencontre
bonjour monsieur le maire bonjour merci
beaucoup a de nous recevoir bah écoutez
c'est un plaisir pour moi je vous invite
à vous vous installez vous êtes maire de
fessenheim vous vous considéré
aujourd'hui comme un maire trahi est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi
on nous a fermé quand même notre poumon
économique sur ce territoire sont sans
raison un environnement sans bonne
raison puisque c'était pas un problème
de sûreté n'est des ni économique ni
écologique donc c'est bien une décision
politique pour par complaisance pour un
peu une partie de l'électorat est donc
aujourd'hui nous sentons trahis surtout
par rapport à à l'évolution du président
sur le dossier nucléaire tout récent
vous vous dites que c'est un choix
politique il ya des arguments aux terres
en termes de sécurité qui ont été
évoqués environnementaux aussi notamment
avec le stockage des déchets nucléaires
etc l'histoire a pourtant démontré
qu'ils avaient des risques avoir une
centrale nucléaire la production
nucléaire est elle une où la houle ou la
production là - la moins mortifère
auxerre qui a généré le moins de décès
au port par rapport à la production qui
a été qui a été mise malgré tchernobyl
malgré fukushima et donc ensuite
l'argument environnemental
le co2 aujourd'hui c'est quand même un
facteur aggravant du réchauffement
climatique donc une centrale nucléaire
produit de l'électricité quasiment sans
émission de co2 donc où est ce qu'on met
les priorités ensuite stockage des
déchets bah oui c'est la seule la seule
filière industrielle qui s'occupe de ces
déchets et qui a des solutions de
déchets c'est bien ce qui gêne les
antinucléaires emmanuel macron a
récemment relancé à le débat notamment
avec lé smr est ce que vous comprenez un
peu ce paradoxe est ce que pour vous
d'ailleurs c'est un paradoxe ça fait des
années qu'on nous dit qu'il faut baisser
la part du nucléaire qu'il faut le
remplacer par de l'éolien part du
renouvelable
tout ça c'est des discours et qui
tiennent pas la route donc c'est même
une escroquerie intellectuelle puisque
jamais le renouvelable ne pourra
remplacer les centrales nucléaires ou
une production de base et donc ça peut
venir en complément est ce que vous vous
aimeriez que fessenheim joue un rôle par
exemple dans les smr alors le site de
fessenheim donc il va démarrer sa phase
du démantèlement donc dans le timing
pour être parfaitement s'inscrire dans
un sûr à être candidate pour un site
pilote dans l'essai mer par exemple
également de 10 développer tout
tout un système de formation pour les
futurs utilisateurs de ces et perdent
une prise de décision rapide sur sur un
site pilote a fait ça il peut aussi
orienter le type de le type du
démantèlement donc est-ce qu'on peut
garder qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu est ce qu
il faut enlever est donc réorientée tout
de suite le site en fonction des besoins
à venir puisque pour l'instant on est on
est un petit peu on a été abandonnée en
rase campagne par le par le gouvernement
fort bien dire ce qui est c'est à dire
ça veut dire que depuis la fermeture
plus rien depuis la fermeture donc il ya
eu ainsi signature d'un projet
territoire qui ce qui est qu'une qu'un
catalogue de belles intentions et donc
qui est qui qui qui aujourd'hui n'ont
aucune réalisation concrète et aucune
perspective aujourd'hui de
réindustralisation sur le site on parle
d'un technocentre donc pour valoriser
les métaux qui sont issus des centrales
nucléaires maintenant on peut tout de
suite imaginé une une suite sur la
production donc avec deux nouveaux
réacteurs même si c'est dans 15 ans dans
20 ans quel a été l'impact de la
fermeture de la centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim sur la vie de la commune
écoutez ce que je vous propose d'aller
découvrir c'est un pack classe heureux
sur le site
avec le dren d'après ce qu'on est là
écoutez là on est sûr là dans la cité
que cela donc il ya 24 logements qui
était dédiée aux logements des deux qui
accueillirent des agents edf et donc
qu'ils ont quittée en fait la commune et
donc c'est des logements qui aujourd'hui
sont vides ça c'est la preuve la plus
visible de la façon dont se
matérialisent l'impact de la fermeture
de fessenheim de la centrale sur votre
ville ba aujourd'hui effectivement c'est
l'effet palpable delà de la fermeture
c'est effectivement ce que ce décès
dévitalisation d'une partie de la
commune sur laquelle on doit on doit
travailler pour pour éviter
effectivement des effets néfastes est ce
que vous aviez un jour imaginer que
cette centrale nucléaire pouvait fermer
ses portes puis son coup vu les
investissements qui ont été faits en
amont pour la pour la sécuriser et vu le
coup le que qques et va générer en par
sonar et par son démantèlement et ccc
absolument improbable du déni on est
passé plutôt à la crédulité et puis et
puis à la colère parce que bon
finalement on se rend compte du gâchis
de cette fermeture et des conséquences
qu'elle va avoir pour ces territoires et
donc qui qui qui pour l'instant sont
très mal compensés alors nucléaire stop
ou encore on vous pose la question ce
soir sur notre compte et d g verte et
france on attend vos réactions et place
maintenant à notre face à face
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
philippe muray l'économie souverainiste
spécialiste également de l'écologie
vient vous êtes l'auteur philippe muller
de comment réaliser la transition
écologique un défi passionnant aux
éditions jean cyrille godefroy merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés en duplex
bonsoir stéphane lhomme ancien porte
parole du réseau sortir du nucléaire
bonsoir stéphane lhomme merci d'être
avec nous une réaction 1 tout d'abord
aux témoignages qu'on vient d'entendre
le maire de fessenheim est évidemment
très énervé il dit remplacer le
nucléaire par des énergies renouvelables
tout ça c'est du discours c'est même de
l'escroquerie intellectuelle vous
partager ce constat philippe muray j'ai
trouvé son intervention très
intéressante et très juste et plein de
bon sens effectivement c'est de
l'escroquerie pourquoi la france a
aujourd'hui
l'électricité avec le moins d'émissions
de co2 en europe avec la suède
l'allemagne qui a fermé son nucléaire à
dix fois plus d'émissions de co2 et
justement parce qu'elle ferme son
nucléaire alors pour quelle raison si on
ferme le nucléaire comme on ferme une
france centrale comme fessenheim que va
falloir le faire on va mettre des
énergies renouvelables du solaire et des
oled de l'éolien qui vont produire la
moitié du temps quand il ya du soleil ou
du vent l'autre moitié du temps les gens
consomment de l'électricité il faut donc
le produire avec des centrales au gaz
pilotable qu'on met en route ou pire des
centrales au charbon donc on voit qu
automatiquement fermés du nucléaire
c'est avoir au moins pour moitié des
énergies fossiles consommer beaucoup
plus de co2 et et mettre beaucoup plus
de co2 d'ailleurs rte ledit réseau de
transport d'electricité de france le 10
si on ferme le nucléaire il va falloir
mettre beaucoup d'énergie renouvelable
mais mettre beaucoup de centrales au gaz
pourquoi parce que l'électricité
passereaux câble l'électricité pas
stockables je finis rapidement en fait
si vous voulez l'académie des sciences
explique que pour stocker deux jours
d'électricité il faut sept ans de
production mondiale de lithium donc on
peut pas stocker l'énergie éolienne et
la remettre dans le réseau quand on veut
donc c'est un gâchis financier de 3
milliards d'euros un outil 3 milliards
d'euros qui a 20 ans à vivre et qu'on a
gâché qu'on a jeté trop tôt si un gâchis
humain avec 1000 personnes qu'ils ont
jetés à la porte émile peine 1000
emplois indirects qui sont détruits et
enfin c'est un gâchis de co2 c'est 3
millions de tonnes de co2 émis en plus
par la france à cause de nos affaires
des problèmes dans l'ordre et dans la
continuité de ce que vous dites
d'ailleurs justement le maire de
fessenheim qui dit aussi j'aimais le
renouvelable ne pourra remplacer des
centrales nucléaires ça ne peut venir
qu'en complément vous êtes un ancien
parole a on le disait du réseau sortir
du nucléaire ça doit vous hérisser le
poil tous ses discours stéphane lhomme
oui alors déjà je suis directeur de
l'observatoire du nucléaire et je
renvoie les spectateurs vers ce
d'excellents sites de notre association
est donc déjà rappelé qu'il ya 36000
communes en france et qui en a 19 qui
ont bénéficié d'un véritable jackpot
pendant 40 ans dont fessenheim et c'est
indécent dont le maire bien écoutez nous
on a enlevé le jackpot et on on ne
trouve pas normal que ça s'arrête et les
1970 communes en france qui n'ont pas de
centrales nucléaires elles font comment
donc il faudrait arrêter de ceux qui
misent et et puis surtout pour revenir
de manière globale il faut rappeler que
sur la planète l'énergie c'est à 80% le
trio carbonées comme on dit c'est à dire
pétrole gaz charbon à 18% les énergies
renouvelables et deux seulement le
nucléaire donc le nucléaire c'est une
énergie il ya une part extrêmement
faibles n'y a qu'en france qu'on ne le
sait pas parce que ça fait 50 ans qu'on
le perd c'est merveilleux sexe
mais en réalité sur la planète 2% de la
consommation mondiale d'énergie une part
très faible est en déclin dix minutes
tout le temps donc ce qu'ils racontent
qu'on va sauver le climat avec le
nucléaire eh bien écoutez c'est en songe
puisque au contraire sur les 400
réacteurs en service sur terre
actuellement les canalais l'immense
majorité qui est en fin de vie et donc
ce qui se passe c'est que les réacteurs
sperme les uns que les autres aux états
unis il y avait 105 d'acteurs mon
service n'a plus 90 et la france a
commencé à fermer aussi non pas pour des
décisions idéologiques comme on essaie
de nous faire croire mais tout
simplement parce que ces réactions sont
délabrés sont en fin de vie et que edf
n'a plus les moyens de mise en beauté
alors la question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire quand
tous ces réacteurs vont s'arrêter c'est
à dire très vite au niveau énergétique
c'est dans dix quinze ans que c'est
demain matin et effectivement on n'a pas
de solution mais c'est pas le nucléaire
il va nous sauver le nucléaire c'est une
énergie 20e siècle c'est fini il faut
plus compter sur le nucléaire alors ça a
suscité pas mal de le débat sur son
autre conte télégramme verte et france
justement gilou lui pense avoir la
solution il dit le nucléaire est un bon
choix abondance d'énergie faible coût
pas de rejets dans l'air et il poursuit
en mai poursuivre avec demandera aussi
d'investir justement et d'innover dans
le traitement du combustible usagé par
la fission et l'air de s'y connaître et
aussi dans les centrales elles mêmes
c'est un petit peu dans la continuité de
ce que vous nous dites stéphane lhomme
c'est que la voilà on va arriver à la
fin ça veut dire philippe muray re qu'il
faut investir davantage désormais dans
de nouvelles centrales qui sont
désormais vieille obsolète oui oui ça
c'est certain mais on n'arrive pas à la
fin ils ont 35 ans il ya des centrales
aux états unis qui ont 62 ans en fait on
quand elles ont 40 ans les centrales en
france on les vérifie on les rénove on
met beaucoup d'argent par le grand
carénage c'est extrêmement rentable edf
a tout à fait les moyens de le faire edf
gagne 4 milliards d'euros ce trimestre
se soumettre on voyait donc bdf a
beaucoup d'argent pour le faire ce n'est
pas un souci mais si on ferme le
nucléaire tout de suite il faut quand
même voir en france si on le ferme et
tout de suite on des gens pourraient pas
produire et qu'on mettrait du
renouvelable et des centrales en gaz ça
serait impossible mais c'est où on
augmenterait de 50 % les émissions de
co2 de la france on mettrait sans
milliard d'euros à la poubelle kippour
durée 25 ans et c'est une filière de
250000 personnes sans compter que c'est
vraiment une énergie de l'avenir la
chine et les etats-unis sont en train de
faire beaucoup de recherches et de
lancer des prototypes de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires encore plus sûre et
avec de l'énergie moins cher il y a
aussi le giec même le giec pour le
climat dit qu'en fait pour le nuc les
dents tous ces scénarios ces quatre
scénarios pour les décideurs en fait il
faut tripler la part d'énergie nucléaire
dans le monde pour avoir moins
d'émissions de co2 et moi je réponds à
monsieur stéphane lhomme c'est à dire
qu'en fait si la france a par habitant
des émissions de co2 inférieures août
c'était rien moyens c'est le grand pays
du monde qui a des émissions de co2 les
plus faibles c'est parce que justement
la moitié de notre énergie utile
l'électricité est complètement
pratiquement complètement décarbonés en
france merci le nucléaire il faut
investir dans toutes les nouvelles
générations on en parlera peut-être
après stéphane lhomme justement ça
serait de l'argent gâché pour vous
d'investir dans les nouvelles filières
nucléaires d'ailleurs c'est ce que veut
faire aussi emmanuel macron avec ses
petits réacteurs notamment c'est une
bêtise pour vous
oui ce sont des filières
n'existe pas ils partent de zéro donc si
on veut sauver la planète
en oubliant qu'il ya des catastrophes
nucléaires déchets radioactifs mais si
on parle même que simplement du climat
construire des réacteurs on voit à
flamanville le réacteur le p r le fameux
the père devait rentrer en service en
et là plus de dix ans de retard
si on construit de nouveaux réacteurs
ils seront effectives dans 20 dans 30
ans donc on voit bien que c'est une
impasse absolue ne jamais oublier que
l'électricité ce n'est que 20 % de
l'énergie consommée dans un pays comme
en france donc le nucléaire ce n'est
qu'une partie de ces 20 % c'est-à-dire
que quand on dit que le nucléaire va
empêcher le réchauffement climatique
c'est une plaisanterie
l'énergie à nouveau que c'est 80% de
l'énergie montrant le gast charbo 18 ans
il renouvela les renouvelables ces
immenses et âmes portant sur la planète
que le nucléaire le nucléaire ce sont
des problèmes gigantesques de
catastrophe offre de déchets d'accès à
lennart à la bombe atomique mais
finalement pour une contribution un film
à la marche et économie de la planète et
à nouveau une contribution diminue le
nucléaire c'est es17 pour stand de
l'électricité dans le monde en 2001 ce
n'est plus que 9% ça diminue tout le
temps et ça va continuer parce que
l'immense majorité des réacteurs sur
terre sont en fin de vie donc
l'humanité cela ça a été très très vite
et c'est évident au niveau énergétique
et au niveau climat mais ce n'est
certainement pas le sauver on le voit
avec les 4
contre courant philippe et puis parce
qu'on veut dire est que monsieur
stéphane lhomme et citoyens du monde qui
dirige la planète et que c'est lui et
qui prend les grandes masses moi ce qui
m'intéresse monsieur c'est pas glam
c'est ce qui se passe en france là où on
peut agir là où on peut voter pour
changer les choses c'est déjà en
regardant petit en regardant autour de
soi et en agissant autour de soi qu'on
va le faire pendant dix ans à la chine
ce qu'elle doit faire
d'ailleurs je vous le signale l'écologie
mondialiste il ya tout les coop il faut
quand même en parler ça fait 26 coop qui
espaces en fait chaque fois ils nous
disent dans un an on va diminuer les
émissions de co2 ça va aller mieux vous
savez combien on a augmenté les
émissions de co2 avec cette vision de
mondialiste 50% de hausse des émissions
de co2 depuis qu'on dit qu'on va les
réduire donc il faut arrêter de regarder
mondialement faut regarder au niveau de
notre pays et faire au mieux possible il
ya autre chose qui est faux qui est dit
en tout cas de fallacieux l'énergie en
fait l'électricité en france c'est la
moitié de l'énergie utile pourquoi si
vous prenez par exemple une unité
d'électricité et que vous la mettez dans
un moteur électrique qui à 90% drôlement
vous prenez une unité de pétrole eh bien
vous avez plus que 30 % de rendement
donc il faut trois unités de pétrole
pour avoir le même rendement
pratiquement qu'une unité d'électricité
en fait ça représente bien la moitié
grosso modo de l'énergie utile consommée
en france donc ce qu'il faut
effectivement et c'est là on voit qu'on
marche sur la tête il faut pas penser à
réduire la production électrique
puisqu'on de se passer de pétrole et de
gaz il faut augmenter la production
électrique en france il faut à peu près
là doublé pour se passer des énergies
fossiles pétrole et gaz et donc
s'appeler de l'électricité qui va servir
soit directement dans des moteurs
électriques soit à fabriquer de
l'hydrogène
pour alimenter toute l'économie et
d'euros gènes des voitures hydrogène
d'être à hydrogène qui existe déjà et
qui sont de série donc là on a vraiment
un moyen d'avoir de l'énergie sans co2
de l'énergie produit en france avec des
emplois français au lieu de dépenser 60
milliards d'euros ailleurs et ça passe
par des énergies renouvelables qui
serviront pour l'hydrogène et de
l'énergie nucléaire qui sert pour
fabriquer de l'électricité pour la
consommation d'électricité une
électricité stable alors il ya un autre
message en a plein celui de fred stop ou
encore les deux à la fois stop car il
faut développer de traitement des
déchets nucléaires où en est on une
interrogation encore pour notre
indépendance énergétique ça ce je sais
que c'est un sujet qui vous tient à
coeur philippe muray re
l'indépendance énergétique
elle passe par le nucléaire stéphane
lhomme
eh bien non c'est pour nous raconte
mais tout le monde voit bien que
lorsqu'il ya des augmentations du prix
du gaz ou d'électricité la france est
touchée ne n'oublions pas que à nouveau
le nucléaire il ne s'occupe que de
l'électricité et l'électricité ce n'est
que 20% du problème donc le lecteur le
nucléaire en france et 17 % de notre
énergie c'est 70 % de notre électricité
mais ce n'est que 17 % de notre énergie
donc le nucléaire alors qu'il est
développé au maximum en france ne nous a
jamais protégé ne nous protège pas au
contraire et nous met en danger et mais
on nous met en danger financièrement
aussi puisque edf maintenant est à bout
de souffle et à areva a fait faillite
edf est quasiment en faillite donc il
faut inventer un autre modèle alors
c'est un peu naïf peut-être mais on sait
que la seule vraie solution ça serait
que d'un point de nous les êtres humains
sur terre en de gan sobre qu'on consomme
très peu d'énergie le moins possible et
qu'on soit raisonnable malheureusement
je crains que ça ne soit pas le cas et à
nouveau le nucléaire c'est 2 % de
l'énergie mondiale c'est pas ça qui va
nous sauver au compteur puisque ça nous
rajoute des catastrophes et des déchets
mais ça n'empêche absolument pas de mes
autres problèmes il aurait rapidement
sur l'indépendance énergétique parce
qu'on va on va pas aborder une autre
idée celle du coup mais notamment en
fait en france on a conservé tout
l'uranium 238 en fait parce que c'est
l'uranium 235 qui sert à produire
d'énergie tout l'uranium 238 on en a
pour milan si on les utilise dans les
nouvelles générations de réacteurs
d'ailleurs le projet astrid que monsieur
macouin arrêté on a mille ans de stock
on a aussi 85 ans de stock de thorium
qui ont sont dans des entrepôts qui ont
été exploitées dans des mines en fait
qui ont été trouvés dans des mines quand
on exploitait des métaux est en fait ce
thorium pas être utilisée aussi dans des
centrales nucléaires à thorium qui sont
encore beaucoup moins dangereuses que
les centrales nucléaires classiques ce
qu'en fait le thorium c'est comme faire
brûler du bois mouillé donc dès que vous
arrêtez de mettre du feu en dessous en
fait cela s'arrête complètement donc on
a toute cette énergie et cette
indépendance énergétique qui à porté de
main maintenant il faut faire des
efforts planifié mettre de l'argent sur
le long terme et certainement pas comme
emmanuel macron dit je ferme fessenheim
est en fait mon projet c'est le
nucléaire avec 6 le père ça ça n'a pas
de sens c'est vrai qu'on parlait de
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
qu'on connaît tous comme en iran
français un fils stéphane lhomme on
enlève les centrales c'est d'ailleurs la
question de boris
nous interpelle pardon encore pour le
nucléaire et par quoi le remplacer
qu'ils soient autant décarbonés et
productifs c'est vrai que c'est souvent
la question qui revient vous allez
mettre des champs d'éoliennes partout
stéphane lhomme qui produisent
finalement peu c'est la critique là qui
revient quand même souvent sur le tapis
alors à nouveau il faut bien le parc
nucléaire actuel on en bénéficie parce
que il a été massivement financés par
l'argent dans les années 70 et 80 mais
c'est quelque chose qui va s'arrêter qui
ne pourra plus être repris puisque les
caisses des états et d'edf sont
complètement vide donc si vous voulez on
a mangé notre pain blanc on a échappé de
peu des catastrophes nucléaires comme
aux plaignants 19 on a eu de la chance
mais ça ça s'arrête maintenant
construire de nouveau versé des sommes
astronomiques pour des réacteurs peu
d'ailleurs ni edf ni areva n'arrive à
construire donc en fait la question est
effectivement réel qu'est ce qu'on va
faire à la fin d'une ère mais on mettra
pas claire parce que c'est impossible à
fabriquer de nouveaux réacteurs edf n'y
arrive pas impossible et je suis lancé
donc on est effectivement dans une très
grande mais on a en effet face à une
impasse en avance en avance on avance on
ne prévoit aucune alternative et ne
l'ont pas oublié sessenheim me fermer un
site de dizaines d'autres réacteurs
relate ce permis en france ce ne sont
pas des questions idéologiques comme
s'il peut faire par edf et les gens qui
soutenaient le nucléaire c'est tout
simplement que ces réacteurs
edf n'a pas les moyens de nouveau et que
tout simplement ce qu on va s'arrêter et
quand je dis va s'arrêter c'est très
bientôt si dans quelques années et on
n'a aucune internet et donc ce qui va
rester
c'est à dire importer massivement de
l'électricité faut savoir que on
critique beaucoup les allemands avec
leurs centrales électriques au charbon
mais ce sont eux qui chauffe la plus
belle parce que avec tous les choses à
gérer mon ami ans eh bien on est obligé
d'importer les hivers parce que notre
modèle centrales nucléaires le chauffage
électrique est absurde et notre solution
vous voyez à faire les grands gens qui
france plus anti france que monsieur
stéphane lhomme c'est pas possible que
je veux dire en plus des torrents de
mensonges dont la france ne se chauffent
pas avec l'électricité allemande de
temps en temps il ya des accords ou la
france exporte beaucoup vers l'allemagne
de temps en temps et dino mais elle n'en
a absolument pas besoin est là des
centrales hydrauliques ou elle qu'elle
peut relaxer pour produire de
l'électricité à la demande donc faut
arrêter les mensonges sur la sécurité
quand même philippe frère parce que
c'est vrai que voilà il ya plein je fais
la sécurité du 2d d'accord j'aurais pour
les a frôlé en france sas et on ne va
pas trop les il n'y a pas eu d'accident
clairement là parce que l'entreprise
attention et public c'est ça qui est
fondamental edf est une entreprise
publique contrairement à l'entreprise
aux entreprises japonaises de production
d'électricité est américaine et donc il
y à une exigence de rentabilité mais qui
vient après la sécurité est justement la
grosse erreur est de mettre des f en
bourse il faut absolument pas que des
francs bourgeois en bourse guidés par le
prix de ses actions la rentabilité
immédiate il faut absolument qu edf soit
100% public pour se préoccuper
uniquement à long terme de la sécurité
et de l'approvisionnement énergétique il
est impossible de financer des centrales
nucléaires mais comment on peut entendre
ça le général de gaulle s'il avait
entendu ça et tous les csss dargaud
liste ils ont mis 200 milliards d'euros
sur la table pour fabriquer les
centrales nucléaires que nous avons ils
ont fait en quinze ans la transition
énergétique c'est à dire qu'ils ont
réussi à ce que la france passent
massivement d'énergies fossiles à
l'énergie nucléaire tout cela parce
qu'ils avaient des ambitions se sont pas
des gens qui comme monsieur stéphane
lhomme sont les bras ballants on peut
rien faire impossible de les fabriquer
on peut les fabriquer ses centrales
alors le p r c'est vrai qu'un réacteur
qui est mal née parce qu'il est né sous
la pression politique avec en fait de
plus en de plus en plus d'un fonctions
au cours du temps pour toujours plus de
sécurité et donc les dessins ont été
sans arrêt modifié d'autant que les
allemands sont rentrés dans le programme
puis en sont sortis quelques années plus
tard ont chamboulé le programme donc
voilà pourquoi ce réacteur est pas
fantastique pour la sécurité optimale
alors il y a effectivement le père et
d'une sécurité encore plus grande que
les centrales d'avant mais il ya ces
petits réacteurs nucléaires et notamment
toute la filière que recherche la chine
en ce moment c'est à dire avec des
selles liquides des selles liquides dont
le liquide de refroidissement
c'est au lieu de l'eau ce qui permet de
ne pas avoir de pression dans les
centrales donc il ya beaucoup moins de
risques et s'il y avait une catastrophe
naturelle comme fukushima qui est
impossible vous déversez en fait tout le
liquide avec le carburant vous le mettez
par une femme dans un circuit extérieur
il se refroidit automatiquement vous
n'avez plus de risque d'accident
importants comme ça s'est passé à
fukushima maintenant il faut avoir envie
de le faire il faut avoir envie
d'investir de planifier sur le long
terme et d'avoir une vision politique
parce que l'énergie ce n'est pas une
vision à deux ans c'est une vision à 20
ans qu'il faut prendre pour que tout le
monde puisse travailler bien dans la
bonne direction stéphane lhomme très
rapidement le mot de la fin parce qu'on
arrive vraiment tout au bout quand vous
voyez tous ces candidats y compris jean
luc mélenchon qui ont un peu rebrousser
chemin qui n'ose pas vraiment qu'ils
n'osent plus vraiment parler de la
sortie du nucléaire
l'enfant parle mais à un horizon plus
lointain que ce qu'ils avaient imaginé
au début on vous dit quoi qu'il ya quand
même un problème d' alternative très
rapidement s'il vous plaît parce qu'on
on arrive avant la fin
oui il ya un problème d'alternative mais
le nucléaire ne succèdera pas au
nucléaire comme il dit cette industrie
etc comme un poulet sans tête et
continuer à courir un jour on nous dit
faut faire les gros réacteur après 90
des petits après rome et la fusion
nucléaire et après les surgénérateurs
c'est une industrie qui ne sait plus où
elle va elle est moribonde je rappelle
le nucléaire c'est des petits 7% de
l'électricité mondiale en 2001 ce n'est
plus de 9% ça fait à peu près 1% de la
consommation mondiale d'énergie donc en
fait c'est une énergie résiduelles qui
va disparaître heureusement mais des
problèmes de la planète et pour nous
tous des humains sur terre et problèmes
d'énergie et de climat reste entier vont
pas être réglé en deux mois mais en tout
cas la disparition de militaires
permettra de se poser les vraies
questions et de gaspiller notre argent
dans le temps eric s'éclaire à la bougie
en attendant je vous taquine merci en
tout cas dans merci beaucoup stéphane
lhomme fini muraire d'avoir été avec
nous avant de nous quitter un autre
appel à témoins puisqu'on parle et
d'énergie si vous avez justement des
problèmes à payer vos factures edf ou si
vous habitez dans un logement qu'on
qualifie de passoire énergétique écrivez
nous envoyez nous vos témoignages sur
l'adresse qui s'affiche sur votre écran
qu'en pensent les français que prélève
donc hrt tv.fr et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain à 20 heures pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé été
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai